[Music]
hey what's up guys i'm qvhd here and the
car that i'm driving right now
is called the tesla model y performance
and this car i was going to do like a
whole big review of it
but since i've already done an autofocus
on the model 3 i think we can keep this
one pretty simple so this car it looks
like a model 3 from many angles
especially when you're outside from the
front you look at it just like a model
three same front end same headlights
same idea but as soon as you see it from
the side then you get like a little more
of that profile you start to see how
much more headroom there is how much
more of that dna from the model x is
coming in so it fits right into the
family and i think it's good as far as
electric cars go that it does look
pretty familiar and then you start to
see some of the bigger differences so on
the model 3 where there was chrome
everywhere every single model y has a
matte black trim around the windows and
the mirrors and the door handles all
matte black trim which is sweet i happen
to think it looks pretty dope and also i
don't know if you can tell on that back
window
every single model y i've seen on the
road has tinted back windows and this
one came with tinted back windows i
think from the factory they're tinting
the back windows and rear window of
every model y
i don't think model s or model x or
model 3 do that but i also think that
looks pretty good and then inside it's
got this huge amount of uninterrupted
glass
for the roof right from the front seats
all the way to behind the back seats
it's perfect for visibility or just
stargazing or whatever you end up being
into but the point is
visibility from pretty much every angle
except rear
is pretty good i think when you look
straight back from this car the tailgate
comes up kind of high and then that roof
line goes down pretty low so the rear is
a little bit tight but other than that
you can see everything oh and also
speaking of the tailgate this car also
has a power liftgate unlike model 3. all
right doug demuro style we have a quark
feature the power liftgate trunk has a
memory just like model s and model x so
typically when you open that power
liftgate from either in the car or
outside it opens all the way this is the
max height this is great but maybe you
don't want to reach up this high every
time or you have a low garage so you can
bring this down a little bit maybe
halfway
and then hold that button for three
seconds
you hear a little chime
so now every time you open the trunk
from here on out that'll be the
memorized height so if you ever go back
into your garage
or that low space again it won't ever
open past the memorized height so if i
did it right it should stop about
halfway
there you go
so model y because of this tailgate has
a lot more uninterrupted storage too
thanks to being a hatchback so without
even putting the seats down thanks to no
transmission and no gas tank you already
have a ton of space in here and it's
nicely separated too and then putting
the seats down gets you like eight feet
of uninterrupted space to the point
where i've seen people put a bed in the
back of the car here like this and camp
in it and the seats powerful by the way
so the switches are on the left side of
the trunk you flip them and it folds
right down i think really though
there's two main things that you think
as you're sitting in the driver's seat
driving a model y number one is that
you're just higher off the ground than a
model three of course and then number
two
is everything else
is just like a model three so the being
higher off the ground part i think
there's some upside and some downside to
that a lot of people like the utility of
being higher off the ground you
obviously have more road clearance you
have more
visibility and you just generally feel
safer when you feel like you can see
more i can see like right over the nose
of this car pretty easily uh so being
higher off the ground is nice literally
it's the same seats as model 3 but on
risers it's easier to get in and out of
the car all that is real
but the downside if you care about like
the sportiness or the feel of the drive
is yeah you are further from the road so
you feel a little less connected to the
road
i'm not like a i'm not a car reviewer
i'm not i'm not going to go top gear on
you is what i'm trying to say um talking
about driving dynamics and all that sort
of thing but pretty clearly when you're
further from the road you feel a little
bit less sporty but that's not to take
away from the performance of this car
this car feels
nimble
agile same
steering wheel same turning radius all
the sport settings on this car
feels
really nice
half my driving around roads like this
is like swerving around potholes roads
are pretty rough in the northeast all
the time and the ride quality in the
performance model y it's actually kind
of harsh sometimes i feel like with the
coil suspension which is the same as the
model 3 and then also with these big
21-inch wheels it's not as forgiving now
if you get the non-performance version
you can get it with smaller wheels it'll
still have the coil suspension but it'll
feel a little more forgiving but
honestly anytime you're driving an
electric car with all the torque you get
right away it's always going to feel
really fast so then when i say it feels
just like a model 3
that's not really that surprising
because this car shares like 75 percent
of its parts with the model 3 inside and
out it almost is a model 3. the interior
is of course almost exactly the same and
it's this like staggeringly minimal
look it's a super clean look to it of
course and there's also literally no
buttons anywhere in the car except the
door handles the steering wheel and the
hazard button which i think is one of
the buttons legally required to be in
the car so everything else is on the
single
center screen
like everything else so that's the
speedometer the navigation
everything and you know i've now that
i've had this car for it's almost been
two weeks actually i've gotten used to a
lot of it
but some of it i still
kind of wish actually was just a regular
butt like i don't know there's just so
many little things that were just used
to being buttons like
the windshield wipers are on the touch
screen anytime you want to change their
speed that's where you'll find the
controls the glove box there's no button
for that even next to the glove box
itself you have to get to that through
the center screen and even even the air
conditioner vents like if you just want
to reach up and adjust the air to make
it point at your face or something
you can't even do that you have to do
that on the screen now it is a super
cool futuristic looking ui where you
have all this directing the air wherever
you want but still sometimes i just want
to just
i just want to just put put the air on
my face like with one little
so i know i don't know there's a lot of
stuff happening on the screen it's all
super cool but at the same time i kind
of wish i had a little bit more manual
control the key
this is the key it's a it's a card key
you can also connect your app but this
is the key and when you get in the model
y it tells you to put your foot on the
brake and put the key right here next to
the armrest
which is this very glossy
slippery surface there's no magnets or
anything
and so as soon as you drive away
or if you accelerate kind of hard which
you might in an electric car or break
kind of hard or do anything that's not a
straight line
it just slides off and falls into the
seat or on the floor
and that's not very elegant so i
understand most people will just use the
app on your phone because you got a car
that can do that you'll use the app but
i kind of wish there was like a
dedicated place that could just hold the
key
and not have it slide all over the place
it would feel a little more
a little more
not professional what's the word
refined i talk about a lot of this stuff
in the model 3 autofocus episode about
how this is a high-tech car with all the
autopilot and computer vision and
software updates and supercharging and
all that stuff and also did a second
video about how tesla's improve over
time so i'll link both of those videos
below the like button if you want to
check them out but i think the main
focus for tesla right now
is
manufacturing
and quality control
those two those are the two main
concerns
starting a long time ago but especially
with model y so at the time of me
recording this this fully loaded spec
model y i'm driving with autopilot costs
about seventy thousand dollars
and that's that's still an expensive car
so they haven't started making all the
cheaper versions yet and so for that
price
even if you're not the most picky person
about that type of stuff which i'm not
actually you still want things to be
built well and even in this model y that
tesla gave me i found it have some
pretty big panel gaps the one back left
over the trunk is pretty serious
potentially letting like water into the
car and i think causing more wind noise
the sun visor on the passenger side is
pretty loose like it could just fall off
if you pull too hard
the hazard button up top is a little bit
indented and just not quite aligned
right and the front trunk lip isn't
quite even all the way around and you
kind of notice it after you look at it
for too long and this is the one tesla
gave me so you know people who are
obviously not getting a review unit that
can be looked over five or six times
before it's shipped off to be in front
of a high-res camera you know people are
gonna also have some of the same issues
potentially more issues as we're still
in this early stage of manufacturing now
like i said i'm personally not actually
very picky about
things like panel gaps like i like high
quality materials but generally i'm
someone who's more focused on when i'm
driving
the actual driving experience so i'm
paying attention to the handling the way
the car feels when you're steering the
zero to 60 and for all of those
fundamentals
and all the extra high-tech stuff like
autopilot
this car
crushes it
it just does
maybe it's kind of like a smartphone
review where
i can only i can only tell you so much
about the phone that you're definitely
gonna get like i can tell you about the
hardware and the performance and
typically how it works
but a lot of the little stuff like that
can be tweaked and fixed with software
updates
you can expect to be probably different
from the phone that i'm reviewing before
it comes out
and that's kind of the same thing here
with a tesla they changed so much stuff
over time
that you know all the fundamentals the
driving the acceleration the autopilot
the features the minimal interior all
that
is still going to be the same about
anyone who orders a model y but a lot of
the smaller stuff like the fit and
finish
and a lot of the little things like the
seats and the little software features
may very well change by the time someone
else gets their model y but as far as
that stuff that i pay attention to that
matters
i'm a big fan of this car
[Music]
you